[Music]
on this thursday night in his own words
a global news exclusive interview with
the doctor blamed for a coveted outbreak
in new brunswick the last two years it
was
the most difficult to hear in
complications at canadian hospitals
we're really only seeing critical
illness in two types of patients
the problems piling up for exhausted
health care workers
tragedy at the manitoba u.s border the
disturbing discovery of four bodies
including a baby's the feds finally
agreed to release more residential
school records the timeline and what's
missing
plus air apparent i haven't quite
processed it i think
a 19 year old's ascent into the record
books
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
tonight in new brunswick where a doctor
blamed for causing a covet-19 outbreak
has launched a lawsuit against the
province the rcmp and facebook dr
jean-robert negola says that he was
falsely singled out as patient zero in
the outbreak which resulted in 41 cases
and two deaths in addition to financial
compensation angola says he wants an
apology an independent investigation
into how he was treated a ross lord sat
down for an exclusive interview with the
doctor who says he's a victim of
politics abuse of power and racism
dr jean-robert angola says he couldn't
sleep for three nights before our
interview knowing he was returning to
new brunswick the place where his life
became a living hell
i think that the last two years it was
the most difficult to hear in my life
after practicing family medicine and
cozy campbellton for seven years dr
angola says his reputation was shattered
and
suddenly
everything is different the good doctor
stopped to be a good doctor to become a
criminal
in may of 2020 and go across the bridge
from campbellton into quebec to pick up
his daughter because her mother was
leaving canada for a family funeral
despite a provincial lockdown dozens of
other essential workers were lawfully
traveling back and forth without
isolating still angola says he checked
to make sure his trip was permitted and
the police tell me dr angola there is no
restriction for the physicians when
angola was diagnosed with covert 19 he
and his daughter entered quarantine but
he was blamed for bringing the virus
into new brunswick and triggering an
outbreak that infected 41 people and
took two lives
he says his accuser was new brunswick
premier blaine higgs this is a
healthcare worker who saw multiple
patients over a two-week period
following their return to new brunswick
we are still contract tracing but we
know this zone is currently at a higher
risk due to the actions of one
irresponsible individual
higgs did not name angola or anyone in
his statement but when some assumed he
was referring to dr angola facebook
erupted in hateful racist abuse and
according to angola death threats
in a lawsuit filed in new brunswick
court angola's lawyers claim the premier
and other government officials abused
their office and have engaged in
deliberate and unlawful conduct the
premier of the province lit the match
right
social media and the rest of it was the
forest fire for dr angola the pressure
became even worse
despite hiring the rcmp for protection
he says his personal security was still
under threat
me i cannot imagine
if there is a crazy
people somewhere
what thing you can do
premier higgs then announced an rcmp
investigation even though there was no
criminal complaint angola's lawsuit
alleges the premier's office and the
rcmp teamed up to find a complainant to
retroactively enable an rcmp operation
that was already underway
the criminal investigation went nowhere
so did charges of violating provincial
covett rules
angola says the repeated efforts to make
him a scapegoat are bewildering
why i'm asking this question till now
he's left to conclude it's because he's
black and an immigrant angola says he's
suing to receive an apology to restore
his reputation and for an independent
investigation into his humiliating
ordeal i need reparations
repressions of my persons my honor
and i want also
that stop
that stop for the future now practicing
medicine in quebec angola says he wants
to continue serving the public and
helping patients for another 20 or 30
years free from the stain of racism and
wrongful accusations
ross lord global news hamilton new
brunswick
many canadian hospitals have been
struggling to deal with covet-19 since
the pandemic began but the omicron wave
is putting an unprecedented strain on
the health care system tonight jeff
semple has a look inside an ontario
hospital that's dealing with an influx
of mostly unvaccinated icu patients
we need one person more staff at this
toronto hospital are performing a
delicate dance
the procedure called proning involves
flipping the unconscious patient onto
their stomach to increase their oxygen
like most in this intensive care unit
the elderly woman has covid19 and she's
unvaccinated now we're really only
seeing critical illness in two types of
patients
them being the unvaccinated patients
and the immunocompromised patients most
in the icu are unvaccinated patients
like dawn who asked us not to show her
face i just feel like there wasn't
enough known
and i wanted to know a little bit more
but in the meantime while the moor is
coming you could be dying she caught the
virus last weekend now she's struggling
to catch her breath i'm going through it
and i'm telling it's not something you
want to play with be careful
do what we're supposed to do and be
vaccinated no i'm terribly sleepy tired
eh really
i just fall asleep standing up
others like fred lying in a hospital bed
but still standing by his decision not
to get vaccinated i'm still
not sure
oh yeah why why do you say that
i don't know it's just a conviction so i
get frustrated when i see
an otherwise healthy person it's a
preventable disease like if these people
got vaccinated
i wouldn't be their doctor i wouldn't be
treating them in the icu over the course
of this pandemic these staff at this
hospital have been performing this
procedure on an almost daily basis but
these days they are doing it with far
fewer hands and that is because this
hospital like so many others is dealing
with an unprecedented staffing shortage
during the first two years of the
pandemic around 500 hospital staff
caught covid19 with omicron they've seen
700 infections just this month the great
majority of our infections come from the
community
at the same time they're also fighting
the fallout from another lockdown a
spike in patients with substance abuse
suicide attempts
and those with other illnesses whose
treatment was delayed by the time this
patient with diabetes saw a doctor her
infection had spread from her toe to her
kidneys the infection has spread
and shut down my kidneys so dialysis is
now
possibly
a life-changing
thing bypass after nearly two years and
five waves some of those doing the heavy
lifting have had enough i decided to be
honest with you reflecting it
i can't continue like this
fatima mohammed has been an icu nurse
for 15 years i'm tired
and overworked
and underpaid
she says many of her colleagues have
quit or taken early retirement she plans
to do the same after the pandemic is
finally over
jeff semple global news toronto
the situation at humber river hospital
is a snapshot of what's happening across
ontario there are more than 4 thousand
people in hospital right now more than
570 are in intensive care the province
says icu admissions are expected to peak
in mid-february
hospitals are struggling under the
strain but officials say there are signs
restrictions are working as mike delay
reports they're now moving ahead with
easing some of those measures
it's been a grim january for ontario's
normally vibrant restaurant industry and
while the ontario government isn't ready
to take all the chairs off the tables as
of january 31st restrictions will begin
to ease and if hospitalizations don't
worsen indoor dining among other things
will return to full capacity on february
21st but it's hardly a sure bet i've
been punched in the head so much over
the last two years we certainly aren't
throwing a party we're not bringing out
the good champagne not at all
the 23 ferkin pubs larry isaacs operates
in ontario were able to keep busy with a
take out menu but they like other
restaurants wouldn't have survived
without taking on an overwhelming amount
of debt
we figure about uh 70 percent of have
taken at least fifty thousand dollars in
debt and about uh
25 percent have taken between a fifty a
hundred thousand and five hundred
thousand dollars in debt programs to
assist with rent and payroll have been
frequently panned as insufficient as was
a recent ten thousand dollar grant when
asked if anything else was being
considered ontario premier doug ford
sidestepped the question our economy is
strong i'm going to say it'll be like
the roaring 20s a booming economy would
be nice but restaurant owners are
doubtful it will be enough as the deal
with supply chain issues in rising food
costs and larry isaac says all those
loans that kept them afloat are about to
come due
our industry makes five points on the
bottom line
to take on all this debt we've taken
over two years we're looking at a four
to five year process in getting us back
financially to get rid of all this debt
and catch up with everyone that's a long
road ahead and there's no guarantee
another lockdown or variant won't get in
the way
microlay global news toronto
to manitoba now where the rcmp has made
a heartbreaking discovery near the u.s
border four people including an infant
have been found dead it's believed they
were trying to cross into the u.s by
foot and died from exposure in freezing
temperatures and now an american man has
been charged in connection with the case
britney greenslight has the details
in the middle of winter and the
punishing prairie cold in the dark and
on foot
no one should die like this all victims
were located approximately 9 to 12
meters from the border
and at this very early stage of the
investigation
it appears that they all died due to
exposure to cold weather on wednesday
morning u.s customs officers apprehended
a group crossing near emerson a manitoba
border town
rcmp were alerted and hours later found
the bodies two adults a teenage boy and
an infant the rcmp's assistant
commissioner was visibly shaken these
victims faced not only the cold weather
but also endless fields
large snow drifts and complete darkness
rcmp feared the crossing was organized
the victims abandoned we're very
concerned that this attempted crossing
may have been facilitated in some way
and that these individuals including an
infant
were left on their own in the middle of
a blizzard when the weather hovered
around minus 35 degrees centigrade
celsius late thursday u.s officials
charged an american man with four counts
of human smuggling court documents state
the group may have been traveling with
others who told police they've been
walking for more than 11 hours
asylum seekers have often crossed to
seek refuge in canada one night in 2017
22 people were intercepted near this
same place but crossing south is less
common i do understand that for some
there may be a great need to get to
another country but this is not the way
you will be risking your life in the
lives of the people you care about if
you try it for now there are so many
questions and the cross-border
investigation is just beginning brittany
greenslade global news winnipeg
western diplomats including canada's
foreign affairs minister are holding
high-level talks on the russian threat
to ukraine canada and its allies are
attempting to present a strong united
front to deter the kremlin from further
escalation but new satellite images
reportedly show russia is ramping up its
military presence in several locations
near its border with ukraine as michael
couture explains there's concern this
could signal an imminent invasion
let there be no doubt at all that if
putin makes this choice russia will pay
a heavy price a day after leaving his
stance on russian aggression unclear the
u.s president was unequivocal any
any assembled russian units move across
ukrainian border that is an invasion and
that biden says will be met with a
severe and coordinated economic response
from the west
for people in eastern ukraine days of
diplomatic dialogue aren't easing
anxieties
i hope they will reach the point that we
and they need and then we'll return to
peace and harmony says this man but
peace may be out of reach
[Applause]
russian military exercises have
intensified the kremlin showing off a
new submarine expected to conduct drills
next month in the mediterranean for now
ukraine's allies are seeking solidarity
in the face of force the united states
together with our allies and partners
have offered a diplomatic path out of
this contrived crisis but unity may not
be easily achieved french president
emmanuel macron is suggesting the
european union forge its own so-called
stability and security pact with moscow
the prime minister is as we speak
looking at a range of options canada
still won't say what if any equipment it
will contribute to bolster ukraine's
military capabilities on the eve of a
critical summit it seems canada's role
is to rally support we are that country
that bring people to the table and make
sure that we can find a solution with
troops already on the ground in ukraine
as part of operation unifier some
believe canada's current actions are key
trying to
keep everybody else at the table and
keep going on this because the moment
you stop talking
we're we're into a bad scene avoiding
that is the goal of the meeting in
geneva friday between the american
secretary of state and russia's foreign
minister
mike liquiter global news ottawa
a long-standing request partially
granted coming up when thousands more
residential school records will be
released
the federal government has agreed to
hand over thousands of historical
documents on residential schools
documents it's been holding back the
hope is the records will help piece
together how the system operated as
david aiken reports the deal comes more
than six years after it was requested by
the truth and reconciliation commission
it's a historic moment
all those kids that were
buried had their own names
names in their own language given to
them by their indigenous parents but
when those kids went to residential
schools the administrators the priests
would not use those names when they went
into the school they became peter john
mary joseph
andrew
those were not their names by selecting
historical photographs their real names
may be part of a vast documentary
archive families have sought for decades
those documents will now be transferred
to the national center for truth and
reconciliation or nctr the nctr
currently holds almost 7 000 survivors
statements and over 5 million records
however we know this is still not a
complete picture and records remain
missing the transfer of some church
records is still under discussion but
survivors say retrieving the full
documentary record is crucial the
records
that will be
handed over
will be
a way
to get at the tour
to be able to tell our stories
to be able to validate and acknowledge
where we have come from as survivors as
uh as a country and the transfer of
those records more than 850 000
documents will begin as early as friday
and should be done within six months
david aiken global news ottawa
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available the
number is toll-free and you can speak in
confidence that number is 1-800-721-0066
a new report says former pope benedict
failed to act on four alleged cases of
sex abuse when he was the archbishop of
munich it is the first formal accusation
that he did not discipline abusive
clerics the allegations are just a few
of the nearly 500 detailed in the report
commissioned by the archdiocese in a
statement the vatican says it will
evaluate the findings 94 year old
benedict has been living in the vatican
since resigning as pontiff in 2013.
lost at sea for more than 24 hours ahead
how one man survived being swept away by
a tsunami
a pristine coral reef has been
discovered off the coast of tahiti more
than 30 meters below sea level
scientists believe the water is just
deep enough to protect it against the
effects of a warming ocean at three
kilometers in length it's one of the
largest reefs found at this depth
the first planes carrying aid reached
tonga five days after it was hit by a
tsunami triggered by an undersea
volcanic eruption australia and new
zealand dispatched supplies and
equipment for shelter cooking and
portable units to clean water much of
the island nation's drinking water is
contaminated by ash japan and china have
also sent aid all by contactless
delivery to help ensure tonga remains
coveted free
a tongan man says he survived more than
24 hours in the ocean after the tsunami
hit his home lasalla falau told a local
radio station he was at home on the
isolated island of atada when he was
swept out to sea saturday evening the 57
year old who struggles to use his legs
says he floated and swam roughly 13
kilometers to two smaller uninhabited
islands before reaching the main island
of tonga tapu sunday night that's where
he was picked up by people in a passing
car he says mental toughness kept him
going
next why nowhere is too far for this
teen pilot who just shattered a world
record
you're watching global national
a teenage pilot has become the youngest
woman by more than a decade to fly
around the world solo nineteen-year-old
zara rutherford landed in belgium today
two months later than planned because of
bad weather as mike armstrong reports
even she admits the goal was a little
out there
on this final stretch zara rutherford
admits there were tears in her eyes
not of sadness simply satisfaction
and pride it's just really crazy i
haven't quite processed it i think
as challenges go this one was a little
over the top 51 000 kilometers flown
over five continents and 52 countries
alone
at just 19 years old she's the youngest
woman to fly solo around the world she
beat the previous record by more than 10
years
both of rutherford's parents are pilots
and understand the feat she just pulled
off
it's extremely difficult what she's done
and it wasn't a given that she would
succeed
the motivation for rutherford's mission
was in a way disappointment as a young
girl her dream was to be a pilot or a
computer scientist but she found there
weren't many females in either field to
look up to as role models so she decided
to try to become one i wanted to you
know fly around the world hopefully have
other girls
see me and think i'd love to fly one day
too
now home for the first time in five
months rutherford wants to hit a
sandwich shop she's missed and spend
some time with her cats her immediate
goals are slightly more modest than the
ones she's just accomplished mike
armstrong global news
wow and that's global national for this
thursday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is the town of
crossfield alberta there are beautiful
spots all over canada please email your
pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you